Sam's about to take over for Andrew Tate
oh [__] yo
you were you were talking before the pot
we're about to get some real tateism
remember I'm not letting my girl drive
my Bugatti you were saying stuff
why are you saying that that's weird
absolutely said nothing like that guys
okay
you got a lot to lose
the second you walked in the studio you
need to adjust yeah yeah okay
um Hollywood ranting and raving about
you
uh but but what we need to know is with
this newfound super stardom you know
it's like like you know how are you
managing managing the expectations of
wifey you know what I mean that's that
[Laughter]
no you know I went through like I went
through like I went through my like
cheating phase and like [__] I did
and we like we went through that like
we'll just Dive Right In we went through
that it's funny that it was a face
it was a phase right it was a phase yeah
yeah I would I think it was a face I'm
on the other side of it so I can look at
it very objectively and go like you
Faithful now yes
don't cheat no don't cheat like I'm like
um past it you know what I mean and like
so I guess even with like all this
because it has been some new attention
like like just immediately and I don't
know if it's like I don't want to say
it's like oh people saw the movie I just
think I'm like I'm walking around with
big dick energy
[Music]
a little Swagger though like yeah energy
my aura is just coming up yeah yeah I
kind of feel when your shit's like
transitioning and I'm like you know this
[__] is transitioning can you yeah so
I'm I'm giving a little bit of that
energy to it so definitely it's been
like it was crazy like I was coming up
and she's gonna be so pissed I'll tell
the story I was we were just at the
cellar and I came out and um we good
it's my titty
um and I came out and I was holding her
hand and this girl walked up like Got
dirt in my face looked at her then was
like hey what what bar are you going to
next oh wow I was like that's just
[__] crazy wow and I was like I'm
going home you know
seeing you a square man
going home
what is happening here that's when you
look at your girl you're like you see
baby it was your face I'm like damn but
now it's like for real like I don't even
be looking at [__] bro wait I don't
know if I um I don't know if I believe
no no same same thing I don't even
register because there's no point what's
the point [__] is good
yeah yeah you've done all that [__]
cheat I'm not gonna do it
register this person like if they just
be like blurs it's just like all right
lady but do you ever look into DMs like
that even Instagram keeps
[Laughter]
the second one
I'll go and I'll like I'll bust the
profile because I want to know what I'm
attracting
wait yeah where's Sam at now you know
and has it yeah you just went from I
don't look at women
I mean as I'm moving throughout my day
yeah there was a time
[Music]
but when you're just at home you're just
taking a [__] or something like that and
you're on Instagram I want to know who's
who's why what I'm getting who's you
want to know how lucky your girl is yeah
yeah yeah
now would you share like if you got a
crazy DM would you be like babe look
look look where I'm at like I tried and
she got mad I did try it it's like a bad
idea what do you mean
but that seems like a bad idea hey your
girl's coming up in the world the
[__] is getting better
you'll be proud of me like give me
surprise give me a high five like just
be my homie right now yeah it did it
didn't work out there what did she say
did she try DM she said I'll beat the
[__] out of you and that [__]
you know my girl yeah she act like she
can fight but I don't believe that she
said yeah I don't yeah I don't believe
she can she always says she like she'll
be somebody up but
I don't think so has she ever tried to
square up on you
yeah of course
yeah I'll be in but I'll be cheating so
that shit's gonna happen
but like shit's gonna happen you know
what I mean like yes she's definitely a
yes I've never pushed her to the limits
yeah yeah now I remember you tell me
some [__] story where I think when we
were in La you were telling me some [__]
about uh when you got caught or her
Casting oh good lord is it is that
private information or yes
we're just we're just some friends
[Music]
[Laughter]
but also tell it yeah
sisters is all behind me as a person
exactly I mean yeah I've been caught
before I don't
I always end up just telling on myself
like once the pressure's on yeah I'm
like man yeah you know I don't I crumble
really quickly but like she's good at
lying like she's like I already know
I know what you did and I'm like oh man
it's just like an interrogation yeah
we got evidence
[Laughter]
and it's like I don't know what she
really does know and what she doesn't
know yeah I don't know the more you go
fishing the more you're like and then
she's good at being like elusive enough
where I'm like she might and then I'm
just like man I can't live like this
yeah so I was like yo
I did the bad thing and have you ever
admitted to the bad thing and then she
thought it was some other [__]
if she did she played I don't know she's
still holding those cards if that's the
case oh some just in case you got to get
an attorney you got to get a lawyer or
something like you need representation
like yeah you can't be snitching on
yourself all the time
I'm out to get I'm done bro how long
y'all been together we've been doing
nothing for 15 years wow how long you
been yeah how clean how was the phase I
mean we went through a whole thing like
that is not super secret like I've
talked about it on pause like we went
through a whole thing and we went
through an actual breakup and stuff like
that the summer I was doing the movie
really like right around that time
um
and it's been like a year so you've been
together 15 years and you've been famous
for a lot of them that's not that's
pretty good that's pretty good that's
like seven percent it's like it's the
rest of her life so also yeah
I know that's crazy
[Music]
but slow down pimp stick like I'm not
like chill the [__] out one this is 15
years off and on like we're American
we're not Indian we don't just
ten years old
dating off and on there's 15 years
I'm just doing math
okay if it's one time a year that's only
15 times no no no it's only I've always
cheated twice thanks thank you cheated
we need an attorney I'll representative
I'll representative they're just out
here like going
[Laughter]
we
broke up
and then we got back together so when I
met her okay so first of all I have a
problem with cheating period so when I
met her I was with somebody so I cheated
with her on the person
like had sex with my girl and the next
day I was like yeah we can't be together
anymore because I knew I wanted to keep
having sex with my girls
over here right so I need to like
how did you break up with your old girl
because you gotta be like I just came
home like hey yeah this ain't working
you know what I'm saying but now she
knows right yeah yeah like yeah she was
just like no she understands she was
pissed
then wait till she sees this we were
together box trash we were together and
then my girl
some better box that's all I had to say
hers was trash but you just found it
like a more Elite better yeah it does
get better that's what they say
so then we got me and my girl together
then she's
she claims you to jail me but she
cheated on me oh we broke up oh wow I
got back with the girl I was with before
that you went back to the old box I went
back to the old box because I was down
bad then then this poor girl bro no I
always feel bad because she was a very
good person I I've always felt really
bad about that Junior Liam white girl no
black girl I've never dated a white girl
cheese up oh [__] now we hey now we're
connecting
um
but we got back together and [__] so we
broke up right she cheated we woke up I
got bad with the other girl really
really do I still I love my girl me and
I was growing up just not working now
get back with my girl she doesn't foul
[__] again whoa whoa Sam you're the
victim here yeah thank you doesn't
follow [__] again we go through it but
we were just young and going through it
it's whatever then I got married dog I
married a whole another person you got
married yes I married a whole another
person because I was like I really let
my girl hit her up and I was like do you
want to be with me you want to run the
streets and she was like I'm having fun
and I was like all right then I gotta
kind of like get you out of my life
because I'm always like kind of on this
you know you know lesbians really do be
moving in with each other after one day
hamster wheel with you so I was like I
just gotta if you don't want to be with
me like that I'm talking about my old
girl I was like if this is not really
gonna happen then I gotta like go yeah
and then probably I met the woman I
married
the day I got married my girl called me
from a Blog number like what the [__]
are you doing like no you know we're
supposed to be you're you're bugging
like divorce this [__] and honestly
Wishing on the phone I was like this
marriage isn't gonna [__] work she's
gonna just she's going to destroy this
oh yeah with all your family there and
[__] because I have blocked her so she
couldn't get contact with me so she
called me from another number wow
oh that's crazy from the pay phone
that's like that's ominous so after that
I was like damn that's crazy then I got
comics to watch hold on hold on don't
break up
don't forget Byron Bowers that's the
craziest thing ever you about to get
married and this girl calls you and says
don't do that [__]
I just said I do and I was like back in
my room changing no oh dude was your
family there like was everyone there no
it was very small we went we went to
like Provincetown it was like a couple
of my cousins it was like a small thing
right
um You didn't believe in this from the
beginning
there's 20 people that's like an open
mic wedding you need to be at this one
it was super small and um
yeah she called me and she was just kind
of like
what are you doing like you know this
isn't Gonna Last what happens when you
hear a voice
I'm like oh no like oh she's back you
know like because I know like I'm like
so in love with her I know yeah that's
why I like blocked her from everything
she should have busted in the church and
like I object that would have been fired
I just like the whole movie whatever but
she so good after that I got common
Swatch and she happened to be here
because she was working at the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show so she
was like yo I want to see you I think we
need to have a conversation like we need
to sit down face to face and have a
conversation that's love too because she
could be trying to get after them
Victoria's Secret models but you guys so
and then I was I mean
she probably was doing a little both
Maybe
[Applause]
a love
thanks
be like really like hey
she's gonna be there I did not plan that
this is circumstance blah blah blah she
must have dinner like she knew all about
her like she you know this was a
important person in my life like I do
believe this requires some closure she
was like cool I trust you which is a bad
decision wow I went half young Metro go
away I had the dinner or whatever
um and then after the dinner I was like
damn like I love her you know I mean
like I kind of like I was like this is
was she gassing you up too she was just
smell good she smells good she looked
great she's so good but also she is my
best friend for real so you guys were
just chopping it up he knows me so she
said real [__] to me she was like you're
settling she was like even if you're not
with me you've never been a person that
settles what the [__] are you doing I
was like damn I am that's like that's
gasoline
I am Southern but it was true I was it
was true I was I met this woman I
married her like quickly with like I
would say maybe nine months without her
I it wasn't like she wasn't bad like the
way that I date and that was just like
in every way
in every way in the future it was just
different it was she was she was dope in
a thousand ways it was just very
different and it was just like
but I don't think it's a bad thing she
was also running from something too it
was two people kind of trying to
distract themselves from yeah
both of us were making like that type of
submission because I was broke as [__]
she made way more money than me she
dated professional people usually I was
like bro dirty comic at this time so
like she was settling in a million ways
too so it wasn't one-sided by any means
but after that [__] I kind of knew and
then the marriage did not work out
partially I think because I was bringing
that energy now I didn't cheat or
anything but I was just bringing that
energy and then there was just some
other problems that were just there and
they were going to be there because we
rushed into it and did take our time and
we weren't like there was just a million
things that was going to go wrong and it
ended up ending in some wild [__] I
talked about on my albums she punched me
in the face and then like the police had
to come and all this [__] and the next
day my girl my fiance came to LA because
she had took everything at the apartment
I was just oh it was a futon and she
took everything so my fiance came to La
like to just helped me like deal with
the court [__] I had to do it and just
be there with me because I was just in
alone in an apartment
all the futon and then like two weeks
from that happening I got SNL and moved
to New York wow and then she came with
me to New York and we've been together
ever since and then the cheating started
on my end hey you start seeing them New
York daddies
and I cheated twice within this five
years period yeah yeah
you're someone who got cheated on and
then just got even yeah I'm very
different it's a walk very different I
was wrong and I have grown that's the
right that's what you're supposed to say
that's what you're supposed to yeah
yeah
that's you've been institutionalized
we've all been there
the other one in nine months this one
you've been with 15 years I think she is
right yeah he's engaged she said my
fiance now yeah when's the wedding 2024.
fall or spring we're trying to get
married you know Martha's been here so
just unless they make a sequel to you
people um
[Laughter]
that first wedding was just as fast as
the one in you people
all right guys we'll take a break for a
second because you never know what could
happen to you in your life what you do
need is Morgan and Morgan that's what
you need Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm they have over
100 offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers listen with over 15 billion
dollars recovered for their clients
Morgan Morgan has proven track record of
fighting to get you your full and fair
compensation okay submitting a claim to
Morgan Morgan it's like ordering take
out then hiring a lawyer so if you're
ever injured you can check out Morgan
and Morgan their fee is free unless they
win think about that there's no cost
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com flagrant or dial
pound law okay that's pound 529 from
your cell phone that's f o r the
people.com flagrant or pounds law